hey this is Kim from Khan Academy and
today I'm talking with some experts
about the 4th amendment this is the 4th
amendment of the Bill of Rights and the
4th amendment deals with unreasonable
search and seizure so here's the
official text of the amendment it says
the right of the people to be secure in
their persons houses papers and effects
against unreasonable searches and
seizures shall not be violated and no
warrants shall issue but upon probable
cause supported by oath or affirmation
and particularly describing the place to
be searched and the persons or things to
be seized to learn more about the Fourth
Amendment I talked to two law professors
who specialized in criminal law
professor Tracy Mears of Yale University
and Professor Orin Kerr of George
Washington University and he's a
particular expert in Criminal Procedure
and computer crime professor Kirke and
he tell us a little bit about what the
Fourth Amendment is and why the framers
were interested in protecting these
rights in particular the Fourth
Amendment is a ban on unreasonable
searches and seizures by the government
it's something the framers were
interested in because they wanted to
limit the government's power at the time
of the framing the English King had
engaged in some pretty bad things that
the framers wanted to stop and one of
those was raiding people's homes with
what was called a general warrant
general warrant was basically a warrant
that said the police could go anywhere
and look for anything without any limit
I honest professor mirrors to explain a
little bit more about general warrants
she's a professor at Yale Law School who
specializes in Criminal Procedure and
criminal law policy they were general
warrants allowing these officials to
search people's homes places papers the
kinds of things that the Fourth
Amendment lists and ways that people
thought was not okay the Fourth
Amendment was from primarily concerned
with a couple of things one
a case involving seditious libel
investigation it's a case called in tech
and a warrant was issued authorizing in
tech that's the subject of the warrant
his arrest and the seizure of all of his
books and papers so that he could prop
be prosecuted for seditious libel that
case isn't as well-known as the second
case which is called the writs of
assistance case and basically the writs
of assistance involved customs
inspectors who are trying to crack down
on smuggling that was affecting Boston's
economy so to aid in that task
inspectors used writs of assistance that
were issued by the King and authorized
the inspectors both to draft assistance
hence the name writs of assistance and
to search any place where smuggled goods
might be concealed the framers wanted to
put an end to that and so they said no
general warrants are allowed and
searches and seizures have to be
reasonable that really means is the
government can't just stop anyone arrest
anyone break into someone's house there
are limits as to what the government can
do but what are those limits what
determines probable cause for a search
and what renders a search and seizure
unreasonable yeah what counts as
unreasonable is a really big question
there are different answers different
courts have suggested but the basic idea
is that first if the government has a
valid warrant a search or seizure is
reasonable if a warrant if a judge has
signed off and said yeah the government
has probable cause to search this place
for particular evidence then the
government can do that and then the
Supreme Court has laid out a bunch of
what they call exceptions to the warrant
requirement which are also reasonable
searches so for example if a person
consents to a search that's reasonable
or in the case of a car a car can be
searched without a warrant based on
probable cause that's called the
automobile exception there are rules
that govern when the police can stop
somebody temporarily when the governor
needs an arrest they need probable cause
they're basically all sorts of rules
that the Supreme Court has laid out on a
bunch of different cases that say what
counts is an unreasonable search or
seizure the Supreme Court has said that
probable cause means a fair probability
that evidence will be found in a
particular place or that a particular
person committed a crime so fair
probability is is the language now
that's not something the Supreme Court
has said you know that's not 50 percent
that doesn't mean it's more probable
than not it just means like there's
pretty good reason to think that there's
evidence to be in a particular place or
at a particular person committed a crime
so it doesn't mean a hunch it doesn't
mean the officer just had the idea pop
into his head but it it also doesn't
mean that the officers certain it's just
there's just gotta be a pretty good
reason but not certainty they think that
person committed the crime or there's
evidence there but when I asked
professor Mears the same question she
wasn't convinced it was so easy to tell
what counts as probable cause so what
counts as a true probable cause to issue
a warrant upon take a second I mean I
taught this today you can't these aren't
questions that you can just simply
answer no one can actually I mean there
is I mean literally I taught today the
fact that there is no real law on what
probable cause is it's an apparently a
factual determination so how does this
work in practice I asked professor Kerr
if it's the case that a police officer
has to convince a judge that there's
probable cause to issue a warrant yeah
so it can come up in two ways in some
cases the Supreme Court says that the
police have to go to a judge first and
get a warrant and then they have to
convince the judge that what they're
about to do is based on probable cause
and in other cases come up when the
government has searched first or
arrested first and then they come back
with the evidence or come back with the
person who was arrested and then there's
a hearing as to whether there was
probable cause for the arrest that
already occurred so either way the
standards are the same it's that fair
probability idea ultimately up to a
judge whether the police were right or
wrong in doing what they did
interesting so if there is a little bit
of prior legwork involved in some cases
what happens in cases when it might be
really important to get evidence say if
there's a bomb threat so there are some
rules that are allow searches or
seizures without a warrant call under
what they call exigent circumstances
that basically means there was an
emergency so the government had to act
without a search warrant and so if
there's a ticking time bomb that they
think is gonna go off in a package and
they've got good reason to think there
is this ticking time bomb in the package
they don't have to say hey we're gonna
go find a judge because by the time they
do that the bomb might have gone off
they can they can search that package
under under this exigent circumstances
idea so that's that's an exception to
the rules although beyond that there's
no difference between a serious case and
a less serious case under the Fourth
Amendment they're kind of all serious
cases so so the courts have to follow
and the police have to follow same rules
and less serious and more serious cases
professor Mears gave me an example of
what seemed like a less serious case but
it's still a really interesting example
of what counts as an unreasonable search
and seizure I'll give you one more case
that I'm sure the high school students
would love and my students love it
it's a case where a person was sitting
in a noodle shop in front of a window
eating a big bowl of noodles clear soup
with noodles and a police officer walks
by the person eating the noodles and
notices something floating in the bowl
of noodles so he enters into the store
where the person is eating the noodles
and the person is left temporarily the
bowl of noodles to get a napkin or go to
the bathroom or something you know
and the police officer approaches the
bowl picks up the person's spoon and
stirs the noodles to see if he can find
anything and some baggies of crack float
to the top did the person have a
reasonable expectation of privacy in
their food in their soup and their soup
how did they rule they ruled that the
stiring was a search so if it is a
search and ie that you have a subjective
and interest in privacy in your soup
that society is prepared to recognize as
reasonable then the police officer would
have to get a warrant before stirring
the soup this raises the question where
do I have Fourth Amendment rights are
some locations protected and not others
the building block of the Fourth
Amendment is really that you have Fourth
Amendment rights in your home in your
pockets in your packages but you don't
have Fourth Amendment rights outside you
don't have Fourth Amendment rights and
what you're doing outside or if the
police want to walk on what they call
open field you know have public streets
that's that you don't have Fourth
Amendment rights in that so thinking
about how the Fourth Amendment applies
just in the physical world if the police
want to break into your home they need a
search warrant if the police want to
watch you walk down the street they
don't need anything it's not a search or
seizure so they can they can do anything
they want just watching you if they want
to arrest you they need probable cause
to believe you've committed a crime so
those are really the building blocks of
the Fourth Amendment that building of
going back to 18th century technology
and then the big question becomes all
right well how do you update that to a
modern world it's also the case that the
Fourth Amendment applies to seizures you
know what police have to show before
they arrest a person or temporarily stop
them or you know briefly Pat their body
on the outside of their body for weapons
all of those questions are Fourth
Amendment questions as are questions
involving how much force police actually
use to effect the arrest once we've
decided that an arrest is legitimate so
yeah we haven't talked about any of
those questions but the Fourth Amendment
governs all of that and remember the
Fourth Amendment governs all of those
topics in a context in which the framers
motivations for enacting the Fourth
Amendment have absolutely nothing
to do with most of those things I just
mentioned but the fourth amendment also
has implications that go beyond warrants
and seizures
professor Mears thinks that one of the
biggest Fourth Amendment issues today is
discretion many people have thought much
more about how the Fourth Amendment
protects privacy then how the Fourth
Amendment
addresses discretion and by discretion
in this case you mean what they get to
decide to do on their own right exactly
so and one way to see the difference
between those two things is to think
about a metal detector in an airport so
long as everyone is required to go
through the metal detector there is no
law enforcement discretion involved so
this is kind of where the the public
safety aspect comes in that if we're all
subject to non-invasive procedures at
the whim of police it's a little
different than if individuals are kind
of plucked for that reason right that
that it's just pointing out that
targeting the targeting of people for
invasions is a different problem than
the invasion problem itself right and so
if all we ever do is thinking think
about privacy invasion without thinking
about the discretion problem then we're
missing something important for a
professor Kerr however the most
important issue at stake today regarding
the Fourth Amendment is how it will
apply to electronic media well the big
question I think is how the Fourth
Amendment is going to apply to searches
and seizures of computers of emails the
internet new technologies that we all
use every day we wake up in the morning
and hop online or go on Twitter or
whatever that whatever you use online
lots and lots of communications online
all around the world and how does the
Fourth Amendment apply to that is
something that the courts are beginning
to answer but they've only started to
answer some really really hard questions
of kind of
translating that physical world concept
of the Fourth Amendment to the world of
computers that we live today so as we've
learned the Fourth Amendment ensures
that government authorities can trade
homes pockets or papers without a
warrant issued by a judge and then only
if there's a probable cause to believe
there's reason for a search what's
tricky is deciding what counts as
probable cause and whether it's
discriminatory to select some people to
search but not others and how do we
translate the Fourth Amendment to a
world where our papers are all digital
should the police be permitted to search
our cellphones our browsing histories or
private social media profiles you can
learn more about the Fourth Amendment by
checking out the National Constitution
Center's interactive Constitution and
Khan Academy's resources on US
government and politics